nous sommes en plein coeur de l'hiver
une période souvent synonyme de sautes
d'humeur et de coups de fatigue qui
peuvent se transformer parfois en blues
hivernal ou même en dépression
saisonnière on vous propose donc une
séance accrochez vous bien et ne nous
quitte et pas de luminothérapie qui
comble le manque de lumière et c'est
avec vous je lis à cigares bonjour
julien bonjour elisabeth n'est pas
qu'une mode le blues hivernal c'est une
réaffectation officiellement reconnus
sous le nom de trouble affectif
saisonnier lite nous tous fouillés
effectivement et les experts estiment
même à 10% la part de la population qui
serait atteinte par ce trouble c'est une
forme de dépression qui est directement
liée à la baisse de luminosité vous
l'avez dit est ce les symptômes en fait
se traduisent par exemple par un manque
de motivation ou par une grande fatigue
et particulièrement l'après midi ou par
une hausse de l'appétit par exemple ces
symptômes pouvant se faire ressentir
particulièrement entre le mois d'octobre
et le mois de mars et c'est
effectivement directement lié au manque
de luminosité qui va non seulement
affecté notre mental mais qui va aussi
affecter notre notre horloge hormonal
comme je vous expliquais dans un instant
et pour cause lors d'une belle journée
d'été par exemple votre corps va être
exposé à environ 50 milles luxe c'est
l'unité dé clairement contre 2000 en
hiver donc c'est un grand écart énorme
pourquoi notre corps at il besoin de
lumière alors je pense qu'il est
important ici de souligner qu'en fait
nous les hommes nous sommes encore des
animaux en un conte est encore très lié
à notre héros de réparer mais en
attendant c'est effectivement sur toi à
l'oublier mais on est encore très liée
en fait au rythme des saisons au rythme
des journées de la nuit et du jour est
en fait ce qui va se passer c'est que la
lumière c'est un moyen naturel pour
pouvoir réguler son corps et pour
pouvoir optimiser ses capacités donc ce
qui va se passer c'est que vous allez
recevoir la lumière du soleil dans votre
oeil votre oeil va envoyer un signal à
votre cerveau pour commencer à sécréter
certains types d'armes notamment le
cortisol qui est en fait ce cette
hormone que l'on appelle de l'énergie
donc quand vous réveillez le matin et
que vous ouvrez vos rideaux que vous
avez du soleil eh bien ça va vous donner
l'énergie de commencer votre journée ça
va aussi sécréter ce que l'on appelle de
la sérotonine et là c'est l'hormone du
bien-être par la même occasion savard
influé sur votre sommeil tout simplement
vous le savez la mélatonine c'est
l'hormone du sommeil cette fois ci et
bien tout au long de la journée vous
allez être exposés à cette lumière
vous allez emmagasiné cette hormone et
c'est que le soir quand votre oeil va en
fait percevoir une baisse de luminosité
qu'il va relâcher cette hormone pour
vous dire il est l'heure d'aller se
coucher ça me permet de faire une
parenthèse vous savez l'utilisation
d'écrans par exemple très tard le soir
et bien c'est une très mauvaise chose
parce que justement ça envoie un mauvais
signal à votre cerveau pour dire que
finalement il n'est pas l'heure de
commencer ce cycle de sommeil enfin très
important aussi ça va augmenter votre
vitamine d c'est essentiel parce que
c'est un cofacteur du calcium c'est à
dire que le calcium a besoin de la
vitamine d pour justement pouvoir se
fixer sur vos os donc ça va renforcer
vos et enfin ça renforce la lumière
renforce votre système immunitaire parce
que ça augmente le nombre de globules
blancs dans le sens qu'ils sont en fait
réputé pour être anti infectieux le
meilleur traitement donc si je vous suis
bien reste la luminothérapie plus
efficace même que les antidépresseurs
dans le cas du blues hivernal absolument
c'est le meilleur moyen il est commencé
il est conseillé de le commencer par
exemple dès qu'il ya une baisse de
luminosité donc dès le mois d'octobre
jusqu'au mois de mars ont fait environ
30 à à 30 minutes à une heure par jour
près évidemment le matin c'est mieux
comme je viens de vous l'expliquer ça
n'a presque aucun intérêt de le faire en
fin d'après midi ou le soir et donc vous
pouvez le faire notamment avec des
lampes de luminothérapie
comme vous voyez ici ou alors ici j'ai
un autre modèle alors là c'est parce que
le problème c'est que vous nous avez
amené un petit objet voilà je vous ai je
vous ai je vous ai amené un petit objet
mais qui est qui est très intéressant
parce que le problème en fait de ces
lampes de luminothérapie c'est qu'il
faut rester devant pendant une heure et
ça peut être contraignant est bien là ce
sont des lunettes chez passer un zoom
est possible levée un peu le les
lunettes voilà voilà voilà
vous avez ici donc des led qui sont au
dessus de vos yeux vous allez donc les
mettre au dessus voilà et en fait ça me
permet ici je peux quand continuer à
regarder à faire des choses à écrire
donc je peux continuer à faire des
choses dans la journée je suis pas
obligé de rester devant mon écran de
luminothérapie et c'est un modèle dont
qui s'appelle luminette qui est créée
par l'entreprise à ses mots swing et
j'en ai besoin la machine et moi qui
suis en plateau toute la journée jeux
wars et vitamine d elisabeth et donc
c'est par l'entreprise lucie med qui est
donc en belgique
alors vous voyez vous avez 4 donc
lumière au su de chèques c'est pas trop
gênant voilà vous pouvez continuer à
fonctionner c'est une lumière blanche
qui est enrichie en lumière bleue est
très important c'est dépourvu évidemment
duvet et d'infrarouges qui sont des
rayons du soleil qui sont dangereux pour
beaucoup de scientifiques du coup la
lumière c'est la médecine du futur c'est
ça je vais l'enlever parce que là je
perd toute crédibilité c'est sarah vous
avez la facture estimée à kidal et mais
effectivement il faut dire qu'il ya
beaucoup de scientifiques dans le monde
entier qui étudie tous et spectre de
lumière le bleu le vert le rouge
notamment pour le soleil mais pour la
santé en général
pourquoi et bien parce que on avance
dans nos compréhension de dd théorie
quantique est en fait nous sommes nous
les êtres musulin de l'énergie compactés
en fait donc c'est normal qu'on réagisse
très bien à toutes saisons de ça nous
permet par exemple aujourd'hui avec
certaines techniques de détoxifier le
soin le foie de d'influer sur le
microbiote intestinal qui lui même est
très liée vous le savez à l'humeur
encore une fois mais aussi par exemple
de gérer certains problèmes cutanés avec
la peau on utilise beaucoup la lumière
et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui avec toutes
les connaissances qu'on a toutes les
nouvelles connaissances sur les théories
quantiques et bien c'est vrai que la
lumière va devenir un outil vraiment clé
de la médecine quantique alger une
question avec tous ces éclairages un
plateau télé ça fonctionne aussi alors
il faut une lumière blanche très très
spécifiques y aller mais en général les
premiers rayons du soleil et ça c'est
aussi très important c'est que c'est
vraiment le matin qui m'ont on va y
penser le malao au saut du lit sinon
vous avez ça donc les petites lunettes
de julia si bien merci beaucoup julien